Seit es sie gibt wird die sommerzeit diskutiert denn ihr nutzen ist sagen wir mal eben
diskutable tatsächlich ist vollkommen umstritten ob sie die
prognostizierten
energieeinsparungen bringt denn wissenschaftlich steht dieser nutzen mehr als in frage
Ist das also alles quatsch und wird sie deshalb bald abgeschafft wir beantworten alle fragen rund um die sommerzeit jetzt mal klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Die geschichte der sommerzeit ist sagen wir mal eine geschichte voller missverständnisse
ein bisschen erinnert sie an den blau milch kanal eine erfundene geschichte
Um einen kanal quer durch die israelische stadt der lavive den gebaut wurde weil irgendein verrückter damit anfing ein loch zu buddeln
Und ein bisschen ist es wohl auch
So bei der sommerzeit denn eigentlich gibt es überhaupt keinen grund für sie
Aber der reihe nach das erste mal wurde die sommerzeit von deutschland und österreich-ungarn während des ersten weltkriegs eingeführt weil man sich da durch
energieeinsparungen versprach mit der eingesparten energie
Damals wurden städte noch mit gas beleuchtet strom wurde mit kohle hergestellt wollte man diese rohstoffe für das militär einsparen doch
Dass man durch das ausnutzen der hellen morgenstunden mehr energie einspart ist mehr als umstritten
Im gegenteil alle bekannten untersuchungen kommen zu dem ergebnis dass der minderverbrauch zu
Vernachlässigen ist das ergebnis war meistens das zwar weniger künstliche beleuchtung benötigt wird aber mehr geheizt wird
2005 fasste die bundesregierung diese erkenntnisse noch mal in einer antwort auf eine kleine anfrage der fdp fraktion
zusammen und heute dürften die auswirkungen sogar umgekehrt seien dadurch
dass die beleuchtung deutlich weniger energie verbraucht als noch vor zehn jahren dürfte der effekt inzwischen umgekehrt sein
Wir dürfen also durch das verstärkte heizen mehr energie verbrauchen aber darüber gibt es keinerlei erkenntnisse
Ohmann es ist schon ein wenig bescheuert ein
insektenforscher der keine ahnung von energieverbräuchen
energiebilanzen undsoweiter hatte trug diese idee erstmals
895 vor george birnen hudson präsentierte seine vermeintlichen erkenntnisse der royal society
Of new zealand und irgendwie hielt sich dann diese irrglaube doch die energieeinsparung so heute gar nicht mehr der grund für die einführung der sommerzeit
Der eigenen grund ist die harmonisierung derzeit in europa um den handel zu erleichtern so steht das
explizit in der stellungnahme der bundesregierung
moment moment
moment
Also wie bitte noch
mal ganz langsam die
Sommerzeit gibt es weil sie andere mal eingeführt haben vollkommen rund und wir uns jetzt in europa nach diesen ländern richten obwohl es gar keinen
Sinn macht und heute wahrscheinlich sogar zu höheren energie verbrauchen führt das ist wirklich wahnsinn das ist echt ein schildbürgerstreich
Das ist ja so als würden wir
Gar kein vergleich an das ist echt so verrückt wie bei per anhalter durch die galaxis
Live ist stranger than fiction kann man wirklich sagen wir sollten wir den
Welt handtuch tag gesetzlich einführen und dabei sind die gesundheitlichen folgen noch nicht berücksichtigt viele menschen beklagen
schlafstörungen schlappheit und eine schwedische studie kommt sogar zu dem ergebnis dass in den tagen nach der zeitumstellung
Mehr menschen einen herzinfarkt erleiden und umfragen kommen auch
Zu dem ergebnis dass die zeitumstellung von der mehrheit der bevölkerung abgelehnt wird so rund 70 prozent sind meistens dagegen doch niemand will sie abschaffen
Allerdings hat das eu parlament jetzt die eu kommission also die regierung von europa beauftragt den nutzen zu
überprüfen und die sommerzeit gegebenenfalls
Abzuschaffen es könnte also vielleicht doch weil es spannend werden mich würde aber mal jetzt interessieren was ihr jetzt nachdem
Er die hintergründe kennt von der zeitumstellung haltet ich starte gleichauf whatsapp eine umfrage dort und nur dort
Werdet ihr auch das ergebnis erfahren wenn er also mitmachen wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer
hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt dort
direkt über mich in der redaktion von krieg so mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen oder
Eben an abstimmungen teilnehmen und mitbestimmen was hier bei pixum so passiert der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht
Das abo mit der genau glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken die genaueste uhr der welt ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran